I have never seen such compassion from a
lot of people in my life toward any
human animal child as I have a lot of
people in the way they interact with the
robot because I should theirs I think
there's something of I I mean I was on
the robot owners chat boards for a good
eight months and the main emotional
benefit is she's never gonna cheat on
you
she's never gonna hurt you she's never
gonna lie to you she doesn't judge you
you know I think that robots help people
and this is part of the work I do with
animals like I do I find therapy and
trained dogs and stuff because there is
this safe space to be authentic your
with this being that doesn't care what
you do for a living doesn't care how
much money you have doesn't care who
you're dating doesn't care what you look
like doesn't care if you have cellulite
whatever you feel safe to be able to
truly you know be present without being
defensive and worrying about eye contact
and being triggered by you know you need
to be perfect and fear of judgment and
all that and robots really can't judge
you yet but they can't judge you and I
think it really puts people at they're
at ease and at their most authentic do
you think you can have a deep connection
with the robot that's not judging or you
do you think you can really have a
relationship with a robot or a human
being that's a safe space or as a
tension mystery danger necessary for a
deep connection I'm gonna speak for
myself and say that I grew up and now
called Combe I identify as a codependent
talked about this stuff before but for
me it's very hard to be in relationship
with a human being without feeling like
I need to perform in some way or deliver
in some way and I don't know if that's
just the people I've been in a
relationship with or or me or my
brokenness but I do think this is kind
of sound really negative and pessimistic
but I do think a lot of our
relationships are projection and a lot
of our relationships are performance and
I don't think I really understood that
until I worked with horses
and most mutations human is nonverbal
right I can say like I love you but that
you're not you don't think I love you
right where's is with animals it's very
direct it's all physical it's all energy
I feel like that with robots too it
feels very what how I say something
doesn't matter
my inflection doesn't really matter and
you thinking that my tone is
disrespectful like you're not filtering
it through all of the bad relationships
you've been in you're not filtering it
through the way your mom talked to you
you're not getting triggered you know I
find that for the most part people don't
always receive things the way that you
intend them to or the way intended and
that makes relationships really murky
you